well there it is the 32-year drought is
over and that is the moment the
los angeles dodgers are became world
series champions after playing the
series in the baseball bubble
they bested the tampa bay race three
games to two look at that celebration
meantime the city of los angeles
throwing quite the party tonight
sports director chris matthews joining
us now with more and chris the world
series champs
not too far from home yeah well you
mentioned that too there are a lot of
dodger fans here in las vegas indeed
and some working right here at channel 8
so it was a big night for the big blue
and you know what everybody's going to
be talking about tomorrow for a long
time now it's one of the craziest
decisions in world series history
game six 2018 cy young winner blake
stell cruising along
had struck out five of the first six
batters through five he allowed one hit
razor up one nothing then came the sixth
he got aj pollock to pop up then allowed
a single to austin barnes
and then to the surprise of everybody
from coast to coast pulled still
after 73 pitches cash did bear in mind
bet seeger and turner were over six
and do up so nick anderson called on oh
he gives up a double the bets
so runners now at second and third and
then comes a wild pitch
dodgers get on the board then betts
scores
on a fielder's choice and just like that
snell and the razor trailing bets would
later seal the deal with a solo shot and
the dodgers win their
first title since 1988 beating the rays
three to one he was fishing a great game
barney let off with a hit i think right
there we had a chance to do something
but i made a pitching change and
seems like that's all we needed all or
that pitching change will be talked
about kevin cash is getting crucified on
social media look at it this way
analytics one
common sense zero this we talked about
for a long time
eighth inning justin turner was pulled
from the game for testing
positive for kovid he wasn't there for
the celebration now the big question a
legit question
if he had gone if this series had gone
to a game seven
how would contact tracing or who would
have been quarantined big big decisions
brian